at the edge of the Black Sea sits the
ruins of the constante casino with only
hints of its former grandeur this MEP
hopes heritage sites across Europe will
see better days
repin arranged it with public geneva so
correct identity identity national or
component alley in europe a national a
steel posture and she rediscovered in
return plus montalais europe na karein
net a Doudna difficult
parliament is voting on making 2018 the
European year of cultural heritage with
a specific budget set aside for it
it's a year where cultural groups
heritage organizations and the youth can
get actively involved educational and
cultural activities will take center
stage challenges will be highlighted
from lack of funding to illegal
trafficking of artifacts MEP s also want
to rev up the economic potential some
300,000 people in the EU work directly
in the sector and about seven point
eight million jobs are indirectly
created for status to leadership una una
hora invested a Gucci Bowl the future
adults
hakuna says there's a lot of work to be
done a year dedicated to Europe's
tangible and intangible treasures is a
start
[Music]